you you can try a thousand different
things and you might
fail 50 of the times you still made 500
things happen
[Music]
all right i think we can get started
yali sar it is a pleasure to have you on
20 minute leaders how are you
i'm good thank you for having me we both
have our coffee and tea
and you know we had a fascinating
two-hour
walk-in conversation here on television
just the other day and i can't even
try to replicate some of the amazing
things that that
we brought up and i learned so much and
i can't wait to learn so much more from
this conversation
but i'd love to focus these 20 minutes
on you and who you are
and your journey and focusing
specifically on two
incredible initiatives raising the bar
and taylor brands
but before we get to those the ali take
me back in time a little bit who who is
yali sar
and how do you end up running a
multi-million dollar startup in tel aviv
cool um okay so i'll take you
back to the back to the start i started
from a little bit of a different
background
i was an actor here in tel aviv i did
television i did theater i did a lot of
children tv and then i kind of found my
way into journalism
spent some time as a political
spokesperson which uh
wound me up actually uh in marketing
i moved to the states i studied in the
states um
and then i opened up a non-profit there
so i was studying
in uh i was studying in colombia
morningside heights
and i wanted to see one second
you jumped way too fast how do you go
from being a child tv star
to being a journalist and going into
politics to going to study
in new york and then creating a
non-profit for education
like i i need the i need a thinking
process
so i think you know a lot of a lot of
the things that
happened to me throughout the years um
kind of just happened
i i strolled into them so i think that
um
initially like acting was never a thing
to me
and then one day i was walking up the
street and um
um you know someone walked up to me and
said do you want to come to an audition
and obviously i didn't think i i might
wound up
you know in a basement somewhere so i
said sure why not
um and i went to this edition which
uh eventually was an addition to a
theater show in one of the national
theaters here in
in israel um so i started doing that
i was 13 or 14 back then
um and that just you know kind of paved
my way there
and from there i went into children tv
um and i did a couple of shows the last
one
we shot over like 120 episodes there
were like wait wait what
yeah everything you can imagine like uh
you know calendars
with your pictures on them and and all
of that
uh not your fault wait i just need the
quick names what are the name what is
the name of that tv show
so the last tv show i did before i
completely stopped was called the leafy
um and it's still it's still it's still
running today thanks to
vod um and
um and then um you know i found myself
at this point in time when i was acting
for
for quite a long time and i realized
you know i i i don't know if this is
what i want to do in life um
and back then i was um going
you know everyone in israel have to go
to the army
and they had this program for military
journalists
so i applied for that and
back at the time you know i wanted to
start writing
and there's a magazine um it's worldwide
magazine but
also in tel aviv called timeout um so
i started writing there just before the
army service
um and my sister was actually the
editor-in-chief of timeout israel
really yeah leon matias
wow okay so probably i
i was there like 14 years ago i was the
youngest writer there
back in the time so young by the way
that they made me use a fictional name
um so wow that's so cool
i did that um i went into the army
and i started doing correspondence
in just um kind of conflict situations
so
jude and samaria and and all around the
area stuff
easy stuff nice stuff uh no really
really complicated stuff but things that
really get you
thinking and get you to understand kind
of the reality that you're living in
and from that understanding i
you know the minute i kind of finished
uh finished with my service
i got an offer to join a political
campaign as a spokesperson
um which i did i joined the
spokespersoning team
and i did that for um it was primaries
we lost uh and
and then um you know i i knew
that i wanted to go to school in the
in the states it was by the way back
back then we were also
kind of shooting music videos uh for
bands here in israel
so i said you know i'm going to study
things
that are in in that field like art
management i initially went to parsons
um i did one semester at parsons then
i realized that i wanted to
try something that was more challenging
for me for the place that
i was in back at the time um i managed
to get a scholarship and
transfer to colombia um
and easy easy peasy
casual and i did that um and i don't
know if you
you probably you did you ever have the
chance to go
into the uh into the campus there it's
beautiful it's a city it's it's a city
within a city
um it's in and it's located in
morningside heights which is basically
harlem
um and what i realized is that you have
this beautiful city within a city
and people can actually walk into a lot
of the less
a lot of the classes for free but none
of the people in the neighborhood do
um so i started this thing called
raising the bar
and the idea was getting um
top-tier professors anyone from like
joseph stiglitz
was was uh one of the uh one of the uh
professors that uh that was there and we
we had a bunch we had like over a
hundred
um and we did everything from like
huge events of a hundred people oh sorry
of like ten thousand people at a night
um to yeah like a hundred bars
throughout the city people are speaking
to just like one-on-ones with people
basically
getting people excited about education
and coming to school because a lot of
the advanced degrees in the states you
can actually get a scholarship for
but if you don't come from the right
background you actually
don't think that you have a chance to do
it so this is exactly what we wanted
people to understand um so we did that
anyway
i have to i have to go back to the
junction where
and and excuse me but you know the most
important part for me
through this show is to understand what
drives people to do what they do and i'm
trying to understand how does a child
childhood actor who goes into journalism
politics then moves to the u.s then goes
to the army moves to the us for college
why does he start a non-profit for
education you're
not american right you don't have
emotional connection to harlem
you we have enough problems you know
around that you know we witness as we go
yeah you're coming to a new location and
no matter the location you're at you
decide that you have to do something
to help those around you why because
there's thousands of other students
that don't have that that thinking
process and they're coming from there
so um i'll give you the
the short reason and the long reason
it's the same reason by the way that a
few years later we started taylor brands
um and we got to where we are today um
the short reason
is you know i'm i'm hyperactive
i'm hyperactive and i always need to do
stuff the the longer
and and more appropriate answer is i
remember
i went to a meeting with a career
consultant right you have in every
college you have career consultants
and you go there and i was actually
going to
to understand what you know what what i
should major in and
um she asked me okay what do you want to
do
um and i looked at her and i was like
you know it has nothing to do with what
i want to study i want to study because
i want to get you know education i want
to get knowledge if i want to do stuff
and then it kind of hit me i can do the
stuff that i want
right away and then i started
you know i i got this notion that i
there's no reason to wait for anything
you can
always do the things that you want to do
um so you know i found myself
trying to figure out what i want to do
in the weekends i didn't want to go out
party i think that when we
discuss by the way about your amazing
life um
you also you know kind of communicated
this urge that
you know you can go to the parties you
can go
and just hang out with people which is
great sometimes but
i always have this urge to do more
things to try and figure out you know
what i can do that would actually be
meaningful
uh with my time um and
i just saw this amazing opportunity
and i said to myself wait you know i can
make this happen there is no reason that
this
haven't hasn't happened yet um and this
is how
we opened up raising the bar and luckily
for us you know it
it went really well and i think that
after a year we started
opening up more branches so right now it
has branches in new york san francisco
hong kong australia yeah in new zealand
they just opened up to
two branches there because it's covered
free um
but um you know it's it's
having this urge to just
we have this amazing tool set right this
tool set is us and this is by the way
something that you learn
as an actor as an actor all you do is
trying to figure out how you can
you know get more out of this tool that
you've been given
and as an actor you you know you
practice mimics you practice your body
language and so forth
but you also have this amazing brain
right
and we all have amazing brains and we
can conjure the
the the most brilliant ideas all of us
um
and usually they just die out on
a paper somewhere or you know at the
back of our heads
but i realized that a lot of the times
the only difference between
you know having that idea die
on the paper or actually doing something
with it
is not being afraid to fail and i think
that's the main thing
that kind of pushes me always it's
it's the idea that you can always try
fail repeat
and there is a sentence that my dad used
to tell me and he said
you know you can try and you know
you can try a thousand different things
and you might
fail 50 of the times you still made 500
things happen
or you can debate yourself
for years whether to do this or that
which one of the ideas that you
you should actually go for and you end
up you know
shooting out two ideas and you might
actually you know
have a you better chances of succeeding
but still you only get two things up and
running
so that's what keeps me going it's just
like let's do
let's do let's do more and the worst
thing that can happen is you're gonna
fail you're gonna get up again and
you're gonna try again
that's exactly why i'm so inspired
inspired by this show because
when i ask you why you're the one who
did this and why what he was successful
the answer wasn't because i had the most
insight or i was the smartest or i was
the best
looking in the room and everybody wanted
to do to do to follow me that wasn't it
your answer was i'm hyperactive and i
need to do stuff and
i know i i'm very privileged to come
from a community that supports failure
encourages failure
as a stepping stone for success and we
all grow up with this
with those quotes like michael jordan
you miss 100 of the shots you don't take
or thomas edison failed
10 000 times before he got that working
light bulb but at the end of the day
most people still don't try and i think
it's a lot because of the community that
we surround ourselves in and if your
community doesn't support
failure and doesn't encourage you to try
and
learn from these failures as a stepping
stone then it's very difficult and
i'm i'm completely inspired by by what
you were just saying so so thank you for
sharing that
and i have to talk about taylor brands
because what you're doing now
is is unbelievable i visited the offices
a few months ago when you were showing
me
a little bit about what you were doing
and one of the first things that you did
that that completely amazed me was you
you know we just got to know each other
and you took me to the white board
and you started i don't know if you
remember this even you started
scribbling you know
the business plan and some thinking
process about something about the next
the next reality of of how algorithms
are going to help
uh going to help us do branding and i
thought to myself like wow
like here is this guy the ceo of a
company that you have over
a hundred employees you said right of
taylor brands
and you're taking time out of your day
to to
to talk with me and feeding off of you
know my reactions
and and and share with me so talking a
little bit about taylor brands and and
some of your thought process as the
as the leader of that amazing group so
um we we have you know a lot of
privilege
uh working at taylor brands and i think
that the main privilege is that
um i talked about my own urge uh to do
stuff
and at teal brands we have the privilege
of helping
other people uh do stuff so today taylor
more than 40 million yeah supports over
20 million
uh businesses worldwide and we help them
you know 30 million
no not just people 20 million businesses
this is insane
yeah this is crazy um and um
you know we we helped them set up they
come to us with an
idea and initially taylor was just a way
to help them create a logo
um so the idea was really i have two
amazing co-founders nadav and tom
and initially we thought about this idea
of creating an algorithm that could
mimic creative tasks i was coming from
world of copywriting
tom my other co-founder comes from a
world of design
and nadav comes from a technical
background the idea was can we
try and figure out how an algorithm
could mimic the same thinking process
that goes in tom's head
um the same decision tree that goes into
tom's head when he's designing
you know a great logo so we initially
did that
and we worked with businesses to create
logos for them
automatically but what we
realized was after they create those
logos the business is still not up and
running
and we started thinking okay how can we
create this platform
that is truly kind of like a one-stop
smb shop how
can we take them by the hand and help
them
make sure that the idea doesn't stay on
paper
it actually you know shoots out to the
world and
maybe it fails maybe it doesn't fail
statistically the majority of smbs
you know will fail um but you know
it you know it keeps us up and up and
going
each and every day and it's it's amazing
and obviously i have to make it parallel
to raising the bar
on one in one hand you're giving
opportunities for education and for
growth
you're breaking down that wall where you
think that you can't even make it
because you don't have the skills you
don't have
the ability to go there and with
tele-brands you're helping people get
their business off the ground and make
those crucial first
steps to even have that ability to make
that jump forward that leap
and to actually and to actually work for
towards that so
what i love what i always love to to
hear from leaders and entrepreneurs and
ceos is
what are some of the most either
exciting times in the whole
journey that i can look forward to as i
start my own startup pretty soon
and also what were some of the most
difficult challenges a lot of people say
that it's lonely that's
that sort of stuff and it's always
really interesting for me my friends to
hear
from somebody who is you know a few
years ahead of us in the journey
um so you know i can only offer
uh insights on my own journey and one of
the things that
um i we love a b testing at taylor it's
something that we do
we probably have like hundreds of a b
tests up and running
at every single moment and one of the
things that you realize
when you a b test is that um some of the
insights that you already have from your
prior experience
you know they don't mean anything uh
when you're trying something new
so you know the things um that
worked for us um and you know in our in
our walk we talked a lot about
um having intention right when you're
starting yes starting anything you wanna
have intention
and you want to be able to do something
that really excites you that is
you know you know bringing something to
the world
taylor because when we started taylor we
were
24 i think 25 at the time um
we really had you know no experience in
the tech world
so our mentality was really about try
fail repeat try fail repeat until
you managed to get you know
some sort of success um i think that
a few things that i learned along the
way is a
bringing experience to your team is
often
you know the best way to avoid all of
these failures
along the way so you might be super
smart
you might know you're the thing that
you're doing
the best but it's still it shouldn't
stop you
and it you know it don't let it stop you
right
from bringing people with experience
that can help you kind of avoid
future mistakes at the same time you
need to give everyone
on the team regardless of the experience
an equal voice
and this is often the best way to kind
of innovate and and find success one of
the things that
we have a tailor is i know that um
whenever we have kind of a feature or
anything else that we're debating what
to do
my voice counts as much as anyone else
on the team as long you know as the data
of someone else is actually you know
more uh more based than the data that i
bring to the table
then their idea is actually going to win
um
because title and experience they don't
really increase the chances of you being
right right they're
um you know the the data should actually
do that thing for you right and i know
awesome
that's amazing no no and and you know
i think that you can start everything
you do with intention and do something
that you feel
is meaningful as you know because
it will make you run longer for it but
um you need to do whatever works
best for you if you have that amazing
intention up
up up front that's amazing if you don't
and you want to start running start
running and
you're going to learn a lot of lessons
along the way
last but not least before you continue i
have to say that i love your comment
about the data
and being intentional because it that
that mindset of
this is what i'm bringing to the table
my experience and my data
if you're on my team no matter what your
title or experience is if you can
show me different data that supports
your idea then you're just as credible
as i'm because i think that a lot of
times people use visionary as an
excuse for for just going headstrong
into something that has no
sensibility now obviously we have
examples of people that went against
data and they were very successful and
they were but but most of the time
it's it's the data i i i i i think what
you're saying is is
absolutely true i think that one of the
things that astonishes me
is how many biographies do you know of
success
right we have thousands of those
probably like tens of thousands of those
how many biographies do you know of
failure
not a lot right so what we do a lot of
the times
is we project we say okay steve jobs
started something out of the garage
exactly right um but i think taylor
brand started from something of similar
nature
but but that's for another story but
yeah i'm sorry to cut you off because
i promise it's a 20 minute 20 minute
show i wish i called it 30 minute
leaders
but we have to end and i have to ask you
my favorite question which is
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um realistically intolerably
optimistic ah you see i was you always
have to make it into a really nice
phrase
but can you repeat that one more time
for me
realistically and tolerably optimistic
i might i might try and adopt that yeah
this is wonderful
and i can't wait for our next walk i'm
learning so much for
from every interaction that we have so
so thank you for the inspiration and
for honestly making the world a better
place and that's a living example of
that so thank you
thank you